I look over and my roommate is on the
phone with a tattoo shop am I really
gonna do this right now when I was kid I
never really thought I'd get a tattoo or
do anything that kind of creeped my
friends called me caution freak when I
was growing up because I wouldn't like
skateboard or do anything I was a kid
with the camera filming them doing
everything the easiest thing I've ever
seen Brian do is he bought a car after
thinking about it for eight months he's
very responsible he's the one that takes
the check to our landlord you know
texting me at 10 o'clock at night like
hey are you gonna be home tonight
being from Colorado I'm a big Denver
Broncos fan and this year they made it
to the Super Bowl Brian was super pumped
I'm sorry the doctors are running to ten
to zero okay I've got nothing right now
I'm starting to get like just kind of
really amped up about the game let's go
every time Denver does something great
I'm like cheering getting into people's
faces being kind of annoying yeah so I
kind of started making these bets saying
like if Peyton Manning throws a pic you
gotta take your shirt off then I yelled
do the worm like right after the Broncos
scored a touchdown and I actually didn't
really even know that I could do the
worm like buy us pizza and he was like
I'll buy three large pizzas for everyone
to have like jump in the pool he was
like then we're just like you know if
the Broncos win are you gonna get a
Super Bowl tattoo you got to get a Super
Bowl tattoo and I was like yeah sure
and then I look over and my roommate is
on the phone with a tattoo shop I'm like
hmm am I really gonna do this right now
I
I don't know
go Ryan
I didn't get the tattoo for like my
friends to appease them and for everyone
to cheer me on it was really fun to just
go for something and do it and like in
the moment just be like this is this is
gonna happen no matter what and like and
all like honestly it kind of like
started making me think like Brian just
got a tattoo and you just went for it
and it is like cliche as it might sound
it started making me think like what are
things that I should just be kind of
like going for and like starting to just
do it's my life
sometimes people are too afraid to take
a risk whether it be a really big thing
or a small thing like getting a Super
Bowl tattoo I think it's important I
think the best part about getting a
tattoo is it's a conversation people ask
questions about it what does it mean as
simple as oh this is when the Broncos
won the Superbowl Super Bowl 50 or it's
something deeper it has like this
meeting but it's a conversation it's
something that relates to you and it's
like memory my name is Brian and I got a
Super Bowl Ted